[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode the
kos and um yep let's get some things out
of the way first really quickly a lot of
people say hey you know I'll watch other
people videos and maybe having a cute
t-shirt on that represents whatever the
statue is you know so they coincide and
make it merge well I'm part of iron
Lords podcast Sundays at 1:00 p.m. where
you can hear us off from anything from
combat sports to statues
mainly video games every console that's
on the market that's relevant it's a
t-shirt right here it's called merch
Lutter merch store and cop the merch
departed iron Lords and you too could be
a lord in your room
king of the statue is you know my
passion this is what I do this is what I
love so anytime you see me get these
statues these are my statues I purchase
them and I share them to the world I
share them to you I share them to
everyone that's either looking to get to
statues and get into statues or want to
know something about statues but the
main thing is I want you guys to stay
collecting and keep that kid inside of
you also for every statue I do I do a
custom Marvel watch right see this is
the spider-man Invicta
alright so to go along with the $700
statue you got a $700 watch not a cheap
$25 t-shirt it's not a king do enough
flossing back to this business so in
this episode I told you we was doing the
spider-man thing and I think I found the
spider-man that I can call my own I
might pull the trigger on it a watch
that I studied it and I had a choice
between the excellent spider-man and the
sideshow spider-man and when I do that
review when I get the statue on hand and
then I'll talk about it more but today
it's about sideshows Premium Format
Green Goblin
now I hemmed in a heart and I thought
who is Spiderman's greatest villain and
like Batman the Joker is Batman's
greatest villain and the reason why the
Joker is Batman's greatest villain is
isn't because he killed Robin isn't
because he is
maniacal and devious and he pushes
Batman to limits no usually the greatest
villain is the yin of the yang of the
character you understand a lot of times
these characters are the same person
just had a different day just had one
day that was terrible that was bad
and you couldn't see these characters
existing without each other this is
Norman Osborn the Green Goblin he Kansas
exists without Peter Parker he's older
Peter Parker's younger he's a scientist
he's his brain is he's a genius
Parker's a genius Parker's a young
scientist Parker looks up to Norman
Osborn this is where the word dynamic is
I believe this is the first time whoa
not to get ahead of myself the Green
Goblin first appeared in spider-man
amazing spider-man number 14 wicked dude
nobody know who he was and he was just
after and over a long arcing of a long
period of time you know he killed Gwen
Stacy
he killed spider-man's in love of his
life now I believe that's probably one
of the earliest times that I realized
that comic books wasn't all jokes and
games and that Spiderman was the hard
luck hero yeah
I knew then that spider-man's life would
be one of power and misery both at the
same time the dualities will coexist
we're inside the Green Goblin he will
suffer power and misery because he is
clinically insane from the potion that
he made the storm that he's made that
made him deranged but it also gave him
super strength speed agility he used his
technical know-how to build that glider
to build those pumpkin bombs to build
that you know the the lays out of his
fingers to shock spider-man disorient
spider-man he is exactly what spider-man
needs to push him forward for a very
long time he was there and tagging izing
baffling maniacal character he even
killed another universe in the Ultimate
Universe he even killed spider-man
that's how we got Miles Morales but
that's a statue for another day many
many books depicted this character as
his true arch enemy now Norman Osborn
will go on to form the Dark Avengers
after the initiative and all this other
stuff and you know he will become the
iron patriot so it's a lot of stories
that's in the Marvel comic books that
Norman Osborn because they were looking
to show a different kind of hierarchy
spider-man's roll galleries in minutes
it's probably the best in comic books so
I needed a Green Goblin
so XM had a Green Goblin that was coming
out but I want it this one this is not
the old g2 og has mixed media this is
the second one the Premium Format one
that is by far depicting what I view the
Green Goblin to be the puff of smoke
luck has he always had that school clown
McDuck this guy is always they could
smoke you know puff the smoke behind the
bike I mean behind the glider and the
way he's angled on the glider with his
arms extended it is a frightening sight
that mass is crazy
decided to with the bombs has the bomb
in his hand and he is chucking the red
spider-man so he killed his love his
life and everybody thought Mary Jane was
the lovers like no Mary Jane came later
but Gwen was first took a long time for
spider-man to recover from that
and it's it's very hard for loss to be
conveyed in books but it was done it was
done accurately that Spiderman wanted
revenge he wanted this guy he wanted to
get to the Green Goblin so this is why
this statue was here because
spider-man's arch enemy is none of them
than the Green Goblin now when we look
at the glider here the glider is
beautiful it's wide enough that it shows
that he's flying on it too details the
mechanics and it the puff of smoke when
the Green Goblin shows up and then his
boobs
I love the boobs all the way up to the
Green Goblin scales on his leg to the to
the real leather statue that he has with
a little real leather strap now sideshow
took some Liberty and changed a little
bit of the outfit to modernize it to
make it go with a modern and I Spider
Man and this is the reason why I might
go with their new Spider Man a new
Premium Format spider-man even though
the oldest Premium Format spider-man
really directly goes with this statue I
just don't like a couple of things on it
but this new one I really like I think
it goes well with this statute I love
the goggles on top of the head
like you know when it really get hectic
he throw on his goggles I am such a
visualization type of dude like when it
comes to comic books I've visualized
that I remember it I absorb it and these
comic books are staple in my life so to
be older and to consider this as a hobby
this is a blessing this is part of the
video when I'm gonna tell you the light
following subscribe and also go to Lords
of gaming net when we have a ton in
opinion pieces we have hard gaming
reviews from Lord addict the best in the
business we have the last word with Lord
kognito and advances yo if y'all are not
checking out Yvonne testers videos on
what's going on with destiny you are
insane the man is a master at what he
does they also break down all in the dlc
also i have a ton of opinion pieces that
you can catch and read right now now we
have a lot of good stuff that's up there
and you can get old episodes of kos also
combat talk with the king that's your
boy old episodes of iron Lords podcast
so if you're new to the podcast and
you're just catching up whether you just
seeing it hey man tune in it's a fun
ride I'm pretty sure that you'll enjoy
it also stick around to check out this
video with all these pitches and all the
video you can see it in all its glory
this statue is amazing if it's something
that's near and dear to me and I'm so
happy that I'm able to bring it to you
thank you again and see you next week
when I bring you something amazing
that the name of the statute quite
possibly
[Music]
[Music]
yes DJ
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes DJ
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
djay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
djay
[Music]